JENNY MURPHY: So welcome to
Building Glassware With the
Google Mirror API.
Today, we're going to show
you some code on
building some Glassware.
Before we get into that,
let's tell you a
little bit about ourselves.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Hi, everyone.
My name's Alain Vongsouvanh.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on
Glass, and this is--
JENNY MURPHY: Hi.
I'm Jenny Murphy.
I'm also a Developer Programs
Engineer on Glass.
So here's our menu for today.
We're going to briefly touch on
the guidelines so you know
how to build some awesome
Glassware.
We're going to cover this really
briefly because it's a
lot of the same information
that Timothy
covered early in a session.
In fact, we assume a little
bit of foreknowledge here.
We assume you're familiar with
Glass, either you attended
Timothy's session, or you have
Glass on right now, or maybe
you visited some of our
partners in the
Glass Sandbox earlier.
But even if you haven't, just
hang tight, take some notes,
and make sure to follow up with
that information like
seeing Timothy's video.
Once we're done with that, we're
going to go through the
components of the Mirror API.
These are the building
blocks that you
use to build Glassware.
We're going to go through each
one and show you some code of
using them in isolation.
Once we're done with that,
we're going to show you a
couple of examples of how you
can put them together to build
some interesting Glassware.
We hope that this will give you
the context that you can
use to build your
own Glassware.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: All right.
Thank you, Jenny.
Sounds really interesting.
But before we dive into the code
and learn how we can use
the Mirror API to build Glass
services, or what we call
Glassware, we'd like to take
a few moments to talk about
guidelines.
So keep in mind that the
Glassware you write
[INAUDIBLE] user, and with the
technology being so close to
the user, it's really important
that the experience
we provide is the
best possible.
That is why we designed
guidelines
around those four points.
I won't go into details into
those because Timothy really
did a great job explaining
them.
If you managed to attend
his sessions--
I bet many of you have--
you should be good to go.
If not, make sure to check his
session when it's back online.
And always keep those guidelines
in mind when you
are designing in Glassware,
[INAUDIBLE] in Glassware, and
testing in Glassware.
Sounds good?
All right.
JENNY MURPHY: Hi.
Let's move on to the Mirror API,
those building blocks I
mentioned before.
Before I get into that, how many
of you here have built
software using RESTful
web services before?
Wow.
Almost everyone.
How about mobile applications
like Android apps?
A good number, and quite
a bit of overlap.
You're going to find that you
can leverage a lot of the
knowledge you already have, a
lot of the experience you have
from those two.
But our perspective is a little
bit different so please
try to keep an open mind.
And as many technical
presentations start, we have
our architecture diagram, and
this one is no different.
We have the Mirror API,
the 10,000 foot view.
Up at the top, we have a green
circle representing the Mirror
API itself, and this is a
collection of RESTful web
services, which is really just a
bunch of directories of JSON
that you work with over HTTPS.
Over on the right side, we have
a box representing Glass
and its connection to the Mirror
API with Glass Sync.
This is something you actually
don't need to
worry too much about.
This is one of the cool parts
of the Mirror API.
We take care of the
synchronization for you.
We handle connectivity,
we handle power, all
that kind of stuff.
You get to focus on the stuff to
the other side, those JSON
messages you send back over
HTTPS and your Glassware, the
code that interacts with
the Mirror API.
And if you're observant,
you may have noticed
I missed one thing.
There were directories of JSON
up there, but we currently
have no way to tell the Mirror
API what user you're
interacting with and no way to
verify that they've given you
access to their data.
This is where OAuth comes in.
We use OAuth to install
Glassware and to give the user
the opportunity to provide
you access to their data.
OAuth is kind of like the valet
keys for the internet.
It gives users the ability to
give you access to just some
of their data out there.
Valet keys that kind of dance,
and I'm going to walk you
through the dance that
we use to do this.
So a new user arrives
at your Glassware.
You don't know who they are.
Maybe it's time to install,
maybe it's time just to hit a
Settings page.
In either case, what you're
going to do is you're going to
redirect then to Google's
OS servers, or
maybe open a pop-up.
You're going to send over all
the permissions you want.
Typically, this is going to be
glass.timeline, but we have
some other permissions like
glass.location which I'll be
going into a little bit later.
The user logs into their Google
account if they're not
already logged in, and then they
see a page where they see
a list of permissions that
you've asked for.
Since your Glassware has been
prudent on the permissions
you're asking for and you have
some really compelling
functionality, of course they're
going say yes and
grant you those permissions.
They get redirected back to your
service, and along with
that redirection comes a code.
Now it's your turn to complete
that three way handshake.
You take that code and you make
a back end request, along
with some details of your
service, and we send you an
access token.
You use this access token to
both identify the user when
you make those requests and to
verify that you have those
permissions.
You include it in a header
on all those requests.
There are a bunch
of steps here.
One cool thing is we have
client libraries in our
Resources that care of almost
all of this heavy lifting for
you, so you don't need to worry
about these details.
But if you want to, you can
code at this level, too.
So now we have access tokens
and we can start using the
Mirror API.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Thank you, Jenny.
So now that the user has
installed your Glassware, it's
time to do stuff with it.
Before we dive into how to write
Glassware, let's talk
about the Mirror API and
what it's made of.
I'm pretty sure many of you
already know, but it's always
good to get a reminder.
So Jenny mentioned that the
Mirror API is a RESTful API,
so it means that it's an API
composed of connections that
you manipulate through
HTTP requests.
So you can update, retrieve,
delete, insert new items to
your collections.
The main collection you're going
to use when you write
your Glassware is the
Timeline collection.
This is how you insert content
into the user's Glass, what we
call Timeline Card, and this is
how you retrieve Timeline
Card from the user's
Glass as well.
Each Glassware has their own
Timeline, so you don't get
access to another Glassware
Timeline.
For example, the Google+
Glassware doesn't have access
to the Gmail Glassware,
and so forth.
Very few exceptions, but that
needs user input and we'll get
into that later.
Now, the example you see on
screen is the most simple
Timeline Card you can insert.
It's text only.
So this is a JSON representation
of a Timeline
item, set the text property to
Hello World, and then send an
authorized post request to the
Timeline collection, and boom,
it's going to be in
the user's Glass.
MALE SPEAKER: Hi everyone.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: It's
as simple as that.
Thanks for the noise.
All right.
Let's jump to the
other example.
So we inserted text, but you can
also insert rich media to
the user's Glass.
The Glass client supports images
and videos, and you
insert those using HTTP
requests as well.
So you can insert media only,
or you can also provide
metadata along with the media.
This is an example of a
multipart HTTP request, but as
Jenny mentioned, we have client
libraries that leverage
all of that for you so
you don't have to do
all the heavy lifting.
And we have extensive
documentation on how to do
that in our reference
documentation.
So now, we have text, we have
media, but sometimes, you want
to add your own branding
as well.
You want to customize
your Timeline Card.
You want to do more stuff,
provide a better
experience to the user.
For that, we have
HTML support.
So you can set HTML
payload into the
Timeline item metadata.
It's as simple as just setting
the HTML into the HTML
Property, and we have a list
of tags that we support and
tags that we don't, like
Script and Link.
All of that is documented in our
Reference Guide as well.
And we also have a built-in CSS
that we encourage you to
use to provide a consistent
experience
across all the Glassware.
Now, let's look at how it
looks like to the code.
So in our slide, we decided to
use Java, but again, the
Mirror API is a RESTful API,
so as long as you have a
language that can communicate
over HTTP, you're good to go.
And Google does provide many
client libraries in different
languages like Java, Python,
PHP, .NET, and so forth.
We have documentation again,
and then you can also check
the Client Libraries
Project page to
learn more about those.
So for Java, how to insert a
Timeline Item, you just create
a new Timeline Item Resource and
then set the text or the
metadata properties you want
for the Timeline Item.
In this example, we're only
saying hello to our Explorers.
And then once you're good with
your Timeline Item, use an
authorized Mirror service and
send an authorized HTTP
request to the user's Glass.
And that's it.
You're done.
You just sent a Timeline Item
to your user's Glass.
It's so simple.
Now, I could talk about this for
20 more minutes, or I can
jump to a demo.
All right.
So we have a tool we built for
you called the Playground
where you can experiment
with the API.
So the Playground is actually
using the Mirror API to send
data to your user's Glass.
So we have a bunch
of templates.
Let's start with a much simpler
one, text only.
So you can simply
edit the text.
Glass Explorers are awesome!
You can see on the right side
of the screen, the JSON
representation.
And then when you're good with
the Timeline Item, just hit
Insert Item.
It's going to use the
API and then send it
to the user's Glass.
Now, let me go to my demo
device with a cable.
Hang into it so I can show
you what the screen
looks like for me.
There we go.
Just now, I just received the
item I just inserted.
It's as simple as that.
Cool.
Now, let's jump back
to the Playground.
We also have template support,
HTML support, and we have
built some templates for you
so you can get started
building your own.
So use the ones you like,
do some modifications
like JFK, et cetera.
Modify it.
You have the JSON on
the right side.
It's kind of complicated to
modify via HTML from the JSON
payload, so you can also
just edit the HTML by
clicking on the tab.
And then when you're happy with
your template, just push
it into your Glass, make sure
it looks the same, copy the
template over into your code,
and you're good to go.
Sounds good?
Cool.
Let's jump back to the slide.
All right.
So right now, we've been doing
one way interaction.
We've been pushing content
to a user of Glass.
But the Glass also lets users
take action on the card you
insert to the users.
You do that by adding more
information into a Timeline
Item Resource that we
call Menu Items.
There are two main categories
of Menu Items, the built-in
ones that usually leverage the
Glass client, like sharing,
which would create a new item--
more on that later--
Get Directions, that uses the
Glass GPS and internal
navigation mode to navigate to
the location provided in the
Timeline Item, and Reply, that
will use a microphone from
Glass to get text input
from the user.
There are many others built in
menu items that we have in our
documentation.
And then we also have
custom menu items.
This is what you use when you
want to provide custom
features to the user.
For example, if you're a news
agency and you're pushing news
content to a user of Glass, you
might want to provide a
way for the user to
save an article or
to vote on an article.
Glass doesn't know what to do
with that, so you simply
provide more information
to us.
You provide an ID, so you get to
know when the user took an
action, you get to know which
action the user took.
And then when we push that to
you, it's up to you to process
the notification.
And then you also need to
provide more information to
us, like the display name,
because we don't know how to
display your custom menu item
in an icon URL that will be
displayed alongside
the display name.
All right.
Now, let's take a quick
look at the code.
So as I mentioned, adding a
menu item is simply adding
more property to the
Timeline Resource.
So again, we create a new
Timeline Item Resource, set
the text, and then set
a built-in menu item.
In our case, we want to let the
user be able to share this
card with other Glassware.
So you simply set the action
to menu item to share, and
then add it to the list
of menu items to
the Timeline Resource.
Add other properties, use the
service object to push it to
Glass, and you're good to go.
Now let's take a quick look
at custom menu items.
So it's almost the same thing.
Create a new Timeline Item,
create a new Menu Item, set
the action to Custom, but now we
need more information from
you so we know what to do.
So you need to set the ID so
when the user takes the
action, the API will push a
notification back to you and
let you know which action
was taken by the user.
And also, we need to know how
to display the menu item.
So simply provide a list of
values with a display name
that will be displayed when the
user selects the list of
menu items and an icon that will
be displayed alongside
the display name.
Add other properties and then
add the Menu Items to the
Timeline Resource and push
it to Glass, and
you're good to go.
That's pretty simple, right?
Cool.
JENNY MURPHY: Next collection.
Next collection.
Contacts.
Here's a flow you're probably
familiar with on Glass.
Pick a photo, in this case,
a wonderful photo of
Chipotle the cat.
Of course you want to share that
with all your friends.
So you tap, you share,
and you share it with
your friends on Google+.
This is a flow of sharing
that shares to contacts.
In this case, the contact
represents
that Circle on Google+.
But contacts can represent other
things, too, anything
you might want to share to.
They might represent an
individual person, they might
represent a group of people like
that circle, or they can
represent things that are a
little bit more abstract, like
a whole Glassware or a feature
within a Glassware like Path.
So let's look at the code that
makes this possible.
So we're going to create a
Contact Resource, we're going
to create an object.
We're going to set an ID.
This ID is passed back in the
notification so that you can
figure out which contact
was tripped
when an item was shared.
It's how you do the correlation
of the round trip.
We're going to set some
display properties.
We're going to set a
name and an icon.
This is what shows up on
your user's Glass.
And one property that's a little
more sophisticated,
we're going to set
Accept Type.
By default, contacts accept any
kind of content on Glass.
Any Timeline Item that has been
marked sharable could be
copied and shared.
So this includes text Timeline
Items, HTML, images, video.
But sometimes, the Glassware may
only want to process one
kind of content.
In this case, this example, we
only want to process images,
so we're only going
to accept cards.
And we specify that using a
Mime Content Type, in this
case, image/*.
Accept any type of image.
Then we insert it,
and that's it.
The contact is made available,
and users can turn it on in My
Glass and start sharing
content with it.
And one more collection,
location.
So say we want to render
something cool, like
this map, in a card.
We want to get the
user's location.
There's a special collection,
which has its own scope that
you can request, and the user
can opt to share their
location with your Glassware.
If they've done that,
you can check for
their latest location.
It's updated about
every 10 minutes.
This one is super easy to use
because we're just pulling
from a collection.
So the code is very simple.
We just do a Get request for
the latest location, which
will give us their
location within
about the past 10 minutes.
Then we do cool stuff with it.
In this case, we're doing
something pretty simple.
We're just printing
out the latitude,
longitude, and accuracy.
That's all there really
is to location.
We read it, we get the
latest location.
So up until now, we've been
talking about pushing content
to Glass and having users
interact with the content
you've pushed to their
Glass device.
But there's really no mechanism
yet for that
information to get from their
Glass back to your Glassware.
What you could actually do is
you could poll all these
collections every couple minutes
and look for changes.
You could look for new
cards that have
been shared with you.
But that's not very efficient.
So we have a better way
with subscriptions.
Subscriptions allow you to
subscribe to notifications
about changes in collections
on Glass.
Kind of flips the
API on its head.
Instead of you posting JSON to
the Mirror API, the Mirror API
will post JSON back to you.
Here's some code that
allows you to do it.
This is code that captures
kind of the first half of
this, subscribing to
notifications.
To subscribe to notifications,
you insert an object into a
collection called subscriptions,
you specify the
collection you want
to monitor.
There are a couple of options.
In this case, you're subscribing
to changes in the
Timeline Collection.
You specify a couple
of identifiers.
These are user-specific
identifiers that are passed
back in all of the notifications
so that you can
verify that this is a bona
fide notification, a true
notification, and you can
identify the user that
triggered that change.
And of course, we need somewhere
to send those
notifications.
So as part of this description,
you specify a
URL, and you'll want
to use an HTTPS URL
to keep things secure.
Once you have all that together,
you insert it, and
after this point, any changes
to the Timeline Collection
will be sent back
to your service.
When the user takes action, or
over time, for the case of
locations, you're going
to be receiving these
pingbacks to that URL.
The structure looks
a lot like the
subscription we just inserted.
Up at the top, we have
the collection.
On one side, we have
the Timeline.
On another case, we have
the Locations.
We have an identifier of the
object that caused the change
in notifications.
If there's a shared item, this
is going to be the ID of that
card in the timeline, same
for a menu trigger.
Another case for Locations on
the other side, that's always
going to be the same ID because
Locations always
surfaces the latest location.
In both cases, in all
notifications that come back,
we're going to echo back to
you the User Token and the
Verify Token so that you can
verify the authenticity and
the user who made
that request.
And in the case of Timeline,
we're also going
to share some metadata.
In this case, we're telling
you upfront from the
notification that this is a
share that triggered this so
you can write cleaner code that
takes advantage of that.
So let's take a look at the
code for processing that
notification.
This code looks a little
different than the code we've
had up here before.
Instead of doing an Insert,
we're responding to a request.
Since we're talking Java today,
we're going to use a
servelet method.
In this case, we're going
to handle a post.
So a post comes on in.
The notification is given to
us in the request body.
So the first thing we're going
to do is pull that request
body and parse the JSON.
We're going to build
an object.
We're going to push it into a
notification using Jackson, so
then we can take action.
First thing we're going
to do is we're going
to verify that data.
We're going to find the user,
we're going to verify the
Verify Token to make sure
everything's on the up and up,
and then we're going to create a
Client Object that allows us
to make calls on their request
using their credentials that
we got from that OAuth flow.
And then the fun stuff starts.
In this case, what we're doing
is if it was a Timeline
notification, we're going to go
fetch that Timeline Item,
we can inspect it, and then we
can take action based on it.
That's the flow you're going
to use for most of your
notifications coming in.
That's all the pieces of the
Mirror API that you can use to
build stuff.
Here they are, Timeline,
Menu Items, Contacts,
Subscriptions, and Locations.
And now let's see how we can
put them together to build
some cool stuff.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: All right.
Thank you, Jenny.
So now we know what the
Mirror API is made of.
It's quite simple but still
pretty powerful.
We'd like now to take a moment
to actually dive into some
demos of Glassware we brought
for you, and we actually have
two of them.
First one, it's probably the
most simple Glassware you
might start with, and we
encourage you to start with
such a Glassware.
Cat Facts.
So everybody loves
Cat Facts, right?
Just simple Glassware.
Just receive new Cat Facts every
few minutes, every few
hours, or when new Cat
Facts are available.
But on a more serious note,
it's actually how the "New
York Times" Glassware or the
CNN Glassware is working.
Every time they get a news
update, they go through a user
database and then send push
notifications to all users who
have subscribed.
Cool.
Now, let's take a look
at the demo.
So again, this is a live demo,
and we've been using random
Cat Facts, so we might have
funny things showing up.
Let's go back to
my Gmail Glass.
Let's see what I got
while talking.
Cats are very lazy and yet
very warm creatures.
I didn't know that.
Did you?
JENNY MURPHY: No, I didn't.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Wow.
Cool.
Now I know.
It's awesome.
It's really simple.
Let's try another one.
We've seen this one, it's
the item I inserted.
Let's see if I have one.
Pure black cats are part of an
ancient cat voodoo cult.
Might be why some people are
scared of black cats.
Cool.
All right.
So this is Cat Facts.
It's actually quite simple.
And we also had a placeholder
for you.
Did you know that cats
can see in the dark?
Again, I didn't know.
That's why I got so spooked
many times by my cat.
Let's see what Cat Facts used
from the Mirror API.
Well, this is a pretty
simple Glassware.
This is the most simple
Glassware you can write.
It's only using the Timeline
collection.
We don't need any other features
from the Mirror API
because we're only pushing
contents to the Glass.
But for instance, if you wanted
to provide a way for a
user to save Cat Facts or to
share Cat Facts with their
friends, you might want to add
menu items, et cetera.
Let's see what the user
flow looks like.
Again, it's pretty simple.
So the user starts
on your website,
authenticate using OAuth 2.0.
Then once you get the user's
token, store the
token in your database.
And when you get a new Cat Fact
or when your Chron Job
runs, just go through your
list of users, get the
credentials, insert a new
service object, insert the
item into the Mirror API,
and we'll take care of
the rest from here.
Google's server will sync with
the user's Glass and
eventually, Cat Facts will be
pushed to the user's Glass and
make the user happy.
Let's take a look at the code.
Again very simple.
We start by getting
a random cat fact.
So this is case, we're only
setting the text, but in your
Glassware, you might want to
use HTML to be able to add
your own branding.
Then we are getting a random cat
fact, but you should get
push notifications from the news
provider you're getting
your information from.
And then you go through all of
your users in your database,
get their credentials, build
a Mirror service.
This is Java.
It might change according to
the language you're using.
And then push the item
to the user's Glass,
to the user's Timeline.
Of course, always check
for exceptions.
Something bad might happen and
you want to catch that so you
don't break the process for
all the rest of the users.
And then that's it.
You just send all the cat facts
to all of the users.
But what we did here was
sending a request
for all of our users.
There might be a better
way to do that.
Instead of sending tons of HTTP
requests every hour when
you get a new update,
you might be able to
have a better process.
And actually, API Stacks, on
which the Mirror API is built
on, supports batching
requests.
The way it works is that you
simply build a multipart HTTP
request composed of sub-HTTP
requests, and you send a
single HTTP request
for all the users.
So all the current libraries
might not
support batch requests.
You should check on
the Project page.
The Java that we're
using here does
support batching requests.
And the way it works is that
you first need to create a
batch callback class that
extends the JSON batch
callback interface.
You need to implement
two methods, on
success and on failure.
This is to keep track of which
requests have failed or which
requests have succeeded.
In our case, we're only
keeping track of
the number of requests.
But in your case, you might want
to keep the request and
retry again, or if the user had
revoked your token, just
remove the user from
the database.
Once you're done implementing
your class, simply create a
Batch Request from the
Mirror service.
So this is unauthorized.
You don't need to authorize
a Batch Request.
Create the new callback object
and then go through all your
users again, get a credentials
from the
database, same as before.
Create a new Insert Request,
but don't execute the
request right now.
Simply add them to the queue
of a Batch Request.
Once you've added all the
sub-requests to the batch,
execute the Batch Request and
check out the results.
That's it.
You just saved bandwidth.
You sent multiple requests into
one SQL request, and with
gzip encoding you might
actually save a lot of
bandwidth and data.
But batching requests doesn't
save you quota, though.
All right, this was
really simple.
Let's jump into another demo
that leverages the API more.
JENNY MURPHY: Now we're going to
show you another Glassware.
This one's a little bit
more sophisticated.
It makes photos better by
adding cats to them.
Let's take a look at it.
So switch into the demo
Glass device.
Does anyone mind if I
take a photograph?
Here we go.
So here's a photo
of all of you.
What I can do now is I can share
it with not a circle,
but with Add a Cat to That.
And we'll loop back in a moment
just to see what happens.
So right now, that's being sent
off to the server to get
processed, have a
cat added to it.
So let's take a look
at how that works.
This uses a few more features
of the Mirror API.
In addition to the Timeline,
which we used to work with the
card up there and also to change
the card once the proof
photo comes back, we also used
the Contacts Collection to add
a contact for adding a cat.
And we subscribed to changes in
the Timeline Collection so
we know when it's time to
add a cat to a photo.
The flow of this Glassware has
a couple different chunks.
First chunk is the
Bootstrap phase.
This is a design pattern we
see in a lot of Glassware,
especially the more
sophisticated ones.
This gets executed whenever a
user installs this Glassware.
We do a few different things
to set them up.
So it starts with the
user authenticating
for the first time.
We store their authentication
credentials so that we can
make requests on their behalf
later, and we immediately do a
couple things.
We're going to insert that
contact so they can share
photos to a Glassware, and we're
also going to insert the
subscription to their changes
in the Timeline so we know
when they share a
photo with us.
Later, when our user is out
about running around, taking
pictures that could be a little
bit better with the
addition of a cat, we do
our interesting stuff.
They take the photo, they
share it with us.
That causes a notification to
be sent to our Glassware.
We fetch the bytes of the photo,
take those bytes and
composite them with the
pictures of the
cat, making it better.
Then we go back to their
Timeline and find the card
that was created when they
shared that, and replace the
image with our improved image.
Let's take a look.
It's already back.
And here is that
photo improved.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNY MURPHY: So let's take a
look at the code that made
that possible.
First, we're going to
go through that
Bootstrap phase again.
This code will look really
familiar because we're just
using the basic features
of those two different
collections.
First, we're adding
that contact.
We're giving it a name, we're
setting display properties and
then ID so we can correlate it
later, and we're setting an
accept type.
Our software can make
any image better.
But we could have made
it more narrow.
For example, if we only wanted
to process JPEGs, we could
have said image/JPEG here.
And then we insert it.
We're also subscribing to
notifications on the Timeline
Collection.
This is pretty much the same
code you saw before.
We're setting an endpoint,
HTTPS, setting tokens, and
subscribing.
Once the Bootstrap phase is
complete, then we are ready to
start handling those
notifications as they come in
from photos being shared.
Pretty similar to last time,
we're using Jackson to parse
those notifications
as they come in.
We're verifying the
notification, we're inspecting
that token and making sure
everything looks clean.
Fetching the user, creating a
client so that we can make
requests and manipulate
their Timeline Item.
And then we call the Add a Cat
to that function to add a cat
to that Timeline Item.
Let's dig into there.
First thing we do up
here is we get the
Timeline Item that impacted.
This is a copy of the original
photo that we took that is
accessible to our Glassware
so that we can
make changes in place.
We're going to go through all of
the attachments that are on
this Timeline Item.
Typically, a card that's taken
from the built-in camera will
only have one attachment, but
another Glassware could have
created and made sharable a
Timeline Item with many
attachments.
We're going to iterate through
all of them and make them all
better, because of course, they
want cats in all of them.
We're going to get the bytes
and process the photo.
We're going to do the
composition in that function.
Then what we're going to do is
we're going to go through each
one of those attachments and
we're going to remove the one
that came to us and replace it
with the improved one so that
the card is replaced in place.
And then finally, we're going to
update the card itself and
make it sharable.
Because of course, you're going
to want to share these
cat improved photos with social
networks and other Glassware.
Then we insert it.
And that was Add
a Cat to That.
Slightly more sophisticated
Glassware.
And yeah, it's silly, but it
shows you how some of those
features in the API can come
together to maybe produce
something you didn't think
was quite obvious.
So let's talk about
next steps.
So we're now two sessions
into the track.
I hope you've enjoyed
them so far.
There are a couple more left and
we'd like to encourage you
to go check them out.
We have Hack Your Glass coming
up in a little while where you
can dive deeper in beyond the
Mirror API on the bleeding
edge in maybe void your warranty
in the process.
And immediately after, we have
a fireside chat with a lot of
the leaders of our team.
Alain and myself and a whole
bunch of developers from the
Glass team are hanging out in
the Sandbox so please come by
later today, maybe tomorrow,
and ask us questions, share
your ideas, and just chat
with us about Glass.
We love hearing from you.
And now and beyond I/O,
we have community
on the web, of course.
You can come and find us on
StackOverflow to ask your
questions about the Mirror
API in Glass.
You can find our sample
code on GitHub.
And if you found an issue or
have a feature request, you
can go to our Issue Track
and report it.
You can find links to all of
these up on developers.googl
e.com/glass/community.
And just for you Explorers
in the audience--
I see a bunch of you--
we have a special community for
you to discuss Glass and
the Mirror API.
So if you have Glass already,
you can go there right now and
discuss with your co-explorers,
and if you
haven't picked up Glass yet,
you'll gain access once you
pick it up.
And that's it.
We have a few minutes
for questions now.
Thank you for listening to us.
So if you'd like to come up
to the microphone to ask
questions, please do.
And after that, we're going
to be in the Sandbox.
So if you have questions we
don't have time to answer,
come ask me there.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Thank you.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So in the Add a Cat example,
you describe removing the
attachments, modifying them,
and then doing an update.
Why is that the pattern?
Why isn't it creating a new
update and pushing that?
Could you describe
the difference
between both of those?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: You mean the
client, creating a copy.
So it's that because the
Glassware, so each Glassware
has access to their own timeline
only, so you don't
get to share a common
timeline.
And so that the user still has
access to the original photo
if they want to share with
other Glasswares.
So we create a copy for you that
only your Glassware has
access to, and you have
ownership over this item.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: So you can
do updates on it, and if
you've been using the Path on
Google+ Glassware, this is
actually what we're doing.
So when you share a photo with
Google+, Google+ reports that
photo and then updates the card
to let the user know that
it has been processed.
And then when they get Plus One
or comments, they'll be
pushed into the bundle.
AUDIENCE: So you don't have to
create a new one and push it?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
You update the existing one.
AUDIENCE: And would there be
any time that you would
actually create a new one?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: It
really depends.
JENNY MURPHY: For bundles.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yeah,
it really depends.
If you have an Instagram
Glassware, for instance, you
might want to create multiple
attachments and add them to
the item so the user can choose
which one they prefer.
AUDIENCE: OK, got it.
Thank you.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
You're welcome.
JENNY MURPHY: How about
from this side?
Question?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm [INAUDIBLE] from Thailand.
I'm wondering if it supports
international language, for
example, Thai language or any
Asian language for displaying
the timeline.
JENNY MURPHY: So the Timeline
Items themselves are UTFA, and
you can actually see from some
of our previous demos, we do
translation.
We're actually putting character
sets from other
languages in there.
So they should work, and if
you encounter a situation
where they don't, please
let us know.
AUDIENCE: How can I know
that it doesn't work?
JENNY MURPHY: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering
if this works.
I saw in the last session
there is a "late-aral"?
menu?
JENNY MURPHY: Literal?
AUDIENCE: Literal, yeah.
And this works for non-English
languages, too?
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, it's
actually one of the really
cool features of Glass is you
can Google for a translation.
So I can ask it how to say
something in another language,
and it reads to me in
that language, too.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
Thank you.
JENNY MURPHY: It's
pretty neat.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Billy Lo from Toronto.
Specifically around the OAuth
integration, it's not quite
clear how a Glass Mirror API
handles the OAuth Refresh of
the token because generally,
there's an expiration of the
OAuth token, right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: This is
actually part of the protocol
and our API Stack.
So usually, what you can do is
either keep the expiry date
you get when you retrieve an
access token, or the other way
you can do that is try to send
a request and look for an
authorized request back
from the API.
So if you get a 401 or 403
back, try to refresh the
token, and if this
is successful,
just use the new token.
AUDIENCE: I see.
Thank you.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: And our
client libraries handle that
for you as well.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
Thank you.
JENNY MURPHY: The slide
we showed was a slight
oversimplification to try and
do OAuth in one slide, so
there's a little more
detail to it.
This side?
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
JENNY MURPHY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: How soon can we send
audio attachments to the
Mirror API?
JENNY MURPHY: Audio
attachments.
So right now, you can attach
photographs and video, and you
can take the photos and embed
them into the card.
Audio attachments is something
we want to support sometime.
I don't have any specific
timeline on it.
You can actually attach
them, they just
don't play right now.
But as we've mentioned before,
it's in developer preview, so
that'll be coming
at some point.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JENNY MURPHY: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hey, this is Andreas
from Minnesota.
I'm interested in lower latency
scenarios and wonder
what round trip times could
be in [INAUDIBLE]
scenarios.
And beyond Mirror, if you're
looking at other APIs which
enable like more real
time things?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: So Timothy
this morning during his
session announced that we're
working on GDK, so Glass
Development Kit.
It's not ready yet.
We're still working on it.
Make sure to file feature
requests if you have any, and
we'll keep you updated when
we have more information.
JENNY MURPHY: And in the
meantime, I recommend you go
to the Hack Your
Glass session.
I think you'll like
the content there.
Switching sides again.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Is there a character
limit for the bodies of the
messages, because it looks like
in the Gmail app, emails
are truncated?
JENNY MURPHY: So for
content and length.
So you can fit about seven lines
comfortably, but they're
variable with fonts.
AUDIENCE: So when you have
multiple cards, though, the
message will keep going?
JENNY MURPHY: Yes, you can
have multiple cards.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
limit on how many
characters you can put?
JENNY MURPHY: There are a
couple ways to do this.
If you're handcrafting HTML,
you kind of frame it so it
fits in there well.
If you have plain text content,
we'll actually page
it for you automatically.
That's how Gmail supports it.
AUDIENCE: Is that a bug
in the Gmail app then?
If you have a long email, it
truncates the message and you
can't read the full
email on Glass.
JENNY MURPHY: You can't
read the full email?
It should be showing
you the full email.
So if you can show that to me,
swing back by the Sandbox, and
we'll take a peek.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JENNY MURPHY: I think we have
time for one more quick one.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Seven seconds.
JENNY MURPHY: Six
seconds left.
AUDIENCE: So I've
been wondering--
Timothy showed this morning the
Facebook application which
allows you to add a caption to
a photo after sharing it.
I've been wondering what kind
of menu item this is.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: It's
a reply menu item.
AUDIENCE: So you can change
the way the standard menu
items are displayed?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
So you can use built-in menu
items and override the display
name and the icon.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: So for other
questions, we'll be at
the Sandbox.
Feel free to swing by and ask
us any questions you have.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
Come talk to us.
We love talking about Glass.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Thank
you for coming.
JENNY MURPHY: Thank
you, everyone.